مقاتله تشق سماء الخرطوم قبل ان تلقي
بصاروخ على هدف ما
مروحيتان تظفران بمركبه عسكريه على الارض
[موسيقى]
فاشهد حقيقي واخر مزيف وقد يكون العكس فكل
شيء في الحرب مباح التزييف والبيانات
الخادعه او حتى الكاذبه سلاح فقط
[موسيقى]
هنا تنشر قوات الدعم السريع مشهدا لطائره
مروحيه سقطت ودبابه انفجرت
فيرد الجيش ببيان نافيا صحه هذه الاخبار
وهنا ينشر الجيش صوره يقول انها تثبت هروب
احمد التي من مخباه بعد هروب طاقم حراسته
ليؤكد الاخير بنفسه انه يقود المعارك من
الخرطوم كل طرف يحاول اظهار تفوقه في
المعركه وانهيار الخصم واقتراب الحسم فيما
يؤكد خبراء ان المعركه سوف تطول
يمكن السيطره في نهايه المطاف على المناطق
المفصليه في الخرطوم بما لها من رمزيه
ويتحول النزاع مره اخرى الى نزاع في
الهوامش والمدن الاخرى ويستطيل امد الصراع
في السودان وهذا ما نخشاه في الحرب
النفسيه تستهدف ثقه الجنود ومعنويات
الافراد فيسارع كل طرف لنشر تسجيلات تظهر
انشقاق او استسلام القاده
اؤكد بانني
لم ولن تصرح لاي جهه
اعلاميه بما يجري الان من احداث
باعتبار ضابطا بالقوات المسلحه
وليست متحدثا باسم اي جهه
الاستخبارات العسكريه
متواجد معها قوات الدعم السريع ومنذ وجود
وجدت كل تعامل جيد
وكرم
ونم يعني شيء الحمد لله
خلال اليومين الماضيين تضاربت الانباء
بشان السيطره على الاماكن الاستراتيجيه
والمواقع الحساسه في الخرطوم وخارج بيانات
تؤكد واخرى تنفيذ معارك حسمت ومواقع سلمت
وكل ذلك كانت تزييفا على الورق لكن على
الارض ما زالت المدافع تدك والقنابل تنفجر
والمباني تشتعل والضحايا يتساقطون
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات